what's going on guys this is rob and if
any of you guys are part of the discord
server you guys know that actually as of
about 10 minutes ago i finished
interviewing tom holland zendaya and
jacob babylon for spiderman no way home
and i asked them two of the questions
that you all had in the discord server
so the video will hopefully go up
tomorrow and uh yeah then hopefully you
guys will be able to find out which one
of you got your question answered having
said that we are picking back up again
with spider-verse now one of the things
we're doing here this actually kind of
opens up initially with spider-man 2099
and again one of the things you remember
is the 2099 universe is where that great
big huge battle between damos and the
various spider-man unfolded and so while
you did have like peter parker and a lot
of those guys who all just kind of took
off to different realities and so on
miguel o'hara from spider-man 2099 he
never left right he's basically been
here the whole time along with lady
spider and with six-armed spider-man
who's actually from a universe and which
we'll talk about here in a second which
is a really really cool story because it
ties into a video that we've already
done and it actually kind of ties into a
character that's going to be in the mcu
so the idea behind this is that we
initially pick up with tyler stone now
tyler stone is basically one of the
high-ranking members of alcomax as those
of you guys may have recall if you've
read spider-man 2099 if you didn't uh
the nature of alcomax is they're
basically like a mega corporation so
think of them as like amazon in the
future is basically what they are right
they're just a really crony company
that's just done some really shady stuff
uh but tyler stone his relationship with
miguel o'hara is a little bit
complicated and the reason why is
because really in the early days of
spider-man 2099 back in the mid-1990s it
was really more that that tyler stone
was kind of a dick and that miguel
o'hara wasn't really a big fan of
alchemax engaging in like human testing
with experiments and things like that
that initially kind of led him to
becoming spider-man in the first place
or at least having a vendetta against it
the other part of that and really the
more personal motivation here is that
tyler stone seemed to basically be
responsible for getting miguel o'hara
addicted to a drug called rapture and
then use the ability of alcomax to
supply that drug as a means to basically
keep miguel on a short leash now in
spider-man 2099 issue number 25 you
actually learn a few things the first is
that tyler stone is the biological
father of miguel o'hara and two miguel
was never actually addicted to to
rapture so basically he was manipulated
by tyler stone and that's why over the
course of marvel's publication history
in addition to just the nefarious things
that alchemax does while miguel o'hara
has always had a vendetta against
alcamax he's always had more of a
personal vendetta against tyler stone
and in fact there's actually been
instances specifically with what was
going on right up until this story was
being written where miguel o'hara had to
actually go back in time or at least was
trapped in the past but had to
essentially ensure that tyler stone
lived because he was his biological
father if tyler stone died before he
could father miguel o'hara miguel o'hara
would cease to exist so literally he had
to save the life of the man he hated in
order to preserve his own existence and
so one of the things that goes on here
is that with tyler stone being head of
what is in effect the secret police of
alchemax though they're basically told
like hey like miguel o'hara just came
back from the past and he's here with a
few other guys now the funny thing about
this is that despite his business savvy
tyler stone doesn't seem to be too
intelligent when it comes to like
technology and things like that the
reason why is because when he asked the
question like he was barely gone for an
hour how did he get back so fast the
question that's given to him is time
doesn't work that way for us he's been
gone for an hour but it could very well
be that he's been stranded wherever he
was at for like months or years right
where it just took him that long to find
a way to get back here and one of the
things just pointed out here which is
kind of interesting is we're like i'm
kind of surprised that we didn't end up
with a paradox where like he came back
before we sent him into the past and
then warned himself to to basically
ensure that we can't trick him into
going into the past and so we basically
have this kind of wonky wild situation
probably like this total breakdown of
reality and things along those lines but
you know leaving out all the crazy
zaniness of it you basically end up just
kind of picking up with the situation
where finally miguel o'hara makes his
presence known to his brother gabe as
well as introducing six-armed spider-man
and lady spider now something that i do
want to point out here is that at first
glance you may think this is
doppelganger for those of you guys who
don't know who doppelganger is and if
you recall our coverage on infinity war
one of the things that magus the future
evil version of adam warlock did is he
basically created doppelgangers of
various characters out there a
doppelganger thanos doppelganger of the
avengers and a doppelganger spider-man
due to his popularity he basically
lingered on following the events of
infinity war but it was basically like
this kind of twisted evil six-armed
version of peter parker the idea here
with this version of peter parker is
that if you guys recall our discussion
on really the character explanation of
michael morbius is we actually solidify
this idea that with his initial
introduction or at least kind of going
into his introduction his first
encounter with spider-man came by way of
peter's attempt to cure himself of
basically being spider-man the result is
that it actually led to him developing
six arms this is an alternate reality
where that was never solved right he
basically kept six arms so again kind of
an interesting little thing there but
the whole idea behind this is that you
end up having of course miguel basically
warning gabe and saying things are kind
of popping off and that we've got
inheritors chasing after us and all that
kind of crazy stuff and where they're
trying to buy their time as best they
can and basically stay hidden that again
because they're spiders and because the
inheritors track spiders deimos is able
to track them down incredibly fast now
remember the motivation of deimos here
is twofold the first is that of course
they're spiders so daimless wants to
basically kill them consume their life
energy and and leave them the second
thing is he's trying to recover his body
remember the inheritors have cloning
technology they have the ability to
basically take their consciousness and
download it into a new cloned body every
single time they're basically killed no
matter what the circumstance is and so
the the various spiders being in
possession of a body of the inheritors
means they can reverse engineer it and
they can find a way to destroy the
inheritors and actually keep them from
being able to download their
consciousness inside of a body demos
basically goes after all of them now the
funny thing here is that lady spider is
not an actual spider character meaning
she didn't really get her powers from
like a radioactive spider bite so she's
not really tied directly into the spider
totems per se she doesn't have that
mystical connection and so where damos
can't really siphon her life energy i
mean i guess he could right but it would
be like eating a carrot when what he
wants is a steak you know what i mean
like it just wouldn't really quite
satiate him in the way that he needs
that he actually kind of entertained
this idea of quote unquote using her for
his own ends now we'll actually find out
what that means when we pick up with
spider woman and the story of jessica
drew because not everything is what it
seems when it comes to the inheritors
that they have as much contradiction and
hypocrisy going on as they do their
belief in their righteous cause but
regardless gabe buys him a little bit of
time when he basically blasts deimos
through like a wall you know using like
this just massive gun and then the fight
basically takes out into the city now
while all that's going on tyler wants to
grab miguel right i mean he basically
wants to like incapacitate spider-man
remove him from the landscape so we
don't have to worry about spider-man
like stopping alcamax like your your
standard traditional like villains
fighting heroes kind of arc right and so
that's why you see like the the secret
police who are out here like these you
know soldier guys and of course damos
rolls right through these i mean at this
point the existence of these guys being
here is really more of a nuisance than
anything else but it does provide a
helpful scenario for miguel o'hara and
the reason why is because for each one
of these guys right like the public eye
as they're referred to for each one of
these guys they've got an up link
directly to tyler stone who runs them
all and so whatever they see in here
tyler stone sees and hears as well and
so that's why where i wouldn't say tyler
stone adopts the philosophy that like
the enemy of my enemy is my friend it is
one of these things where he's like okay
so this guy deimos or whoever this guy
is is a far more credible threat in the
moment here and now and that miguel
o'hara and i at the very least have some
kind of like loose goal which is to see
this guy destroy now tyler stone doesn't
really know enough to know about
anything that's going on here and in
fact his desire to appease miguel o'hara
is really rooted more in the fact that
miguel's pissed right he's like you
tricked me or you sent me back to 2014.
like ordinarily i would beat the
absolute crap out of you and you know
just as well as i do i could right like
this little cat and mouse game we have
like it really is just a game we play
but at the end of the day like i could
kill you where you are so if you don't
want me to do that out of just sheer
anger and irritation understand that you
are correct when you surmise the
situation and say i'm not worried about
you right now because i've got more
important things to worry about but what
i do need from you is to literally
activate something for me right like he
basically tells him alchemax 482 lab c
you know exactly what i mean have it
ready for me and so where miguel o'hara
basically leads you know deimos to this
particular location once everything pops
off and in fact you know lady spider
kind of does what she can uh in the the
fight between the two that is really
more of of miguel playing possum to a
degree right i mean not in so far that
like he fakes his own injury or death
but basically luring deimos to this spot
in alcamax and then as soon as damos
gets there he immediately goes to attack
miguel o'hara and then just gets
electrocuted and the reason why is
because miguel has him trapped in what's
basically a stasis cell now here's an
important thing to grasp here and this
is one of the reasons why i always kind
of felt like miguel o'hara in a lot of
ways was a more capable version of
spider-man of peter parker it's not
necessarily that he's better but the
technology of the time of course is more
advanced than it is in the main marvel
universe but peter parker was always
more of like a comedic character and so
it would usually break down to him just
kind of pissing off the villain and then
letting the villain basically like
defeat themselves by way of their
carelessness because they let their
anger get the better of them miguel was
a lot more methodical and i would say
even to a degree he was a lot darker
than peter parker was but i think there
was more methodology that went into
miguel o'hara being spider-man than it
did with peter parker being spider-man
and that's one of the reasons why miguel
o'hara when he first popped up really
did develop his own fan base like people
loved miguel o'hara back in the day
because he was just so starkly different
from what you normally saw but
regardless with that being said guys
we're gonna bring this video to an end
thank you guys for watching keep your
eyes out for part two we will have that
up later on today and i will catch you
all later
peace